diese strähnige vorne gefällt mir nicht
dann schneiden weil die einfach mal kurz
ab
was glaubt willkommen beim neuen video
in letzter zeit kam mir wirklich oft mal
so diese teile so was jungs wirklich
machen bei blablabla was mädchen
wirklich machen bei barbara kommt immer
heftig an
ihr habt wirklich jetzt diese folge
heftig nachgefragt was machen jungs
wirklich vom date vom ersten welt ich
habe mir ein bisschen gedanken gemacht
so und mir sind so ein paar sachen
eingefallen die man da vielleicht
einbauen könnte darum geht es heute ich
will eigentlich gar nicht lange lagern
gefangen direkt an wenn es euch gefällt
und jedoch mehr davon sehen wollt wenn
ihr auch was mädchen wirklich vor dem
ersten date machen sehen wollt dann
lassen doch nach oben da und schreibt
als mädchen in die kommentare was macht
dir eklig vorm ersten date weil ich kann
es ja nicht wissen ich will den jungen
ja dann will ich sagen let's go ja heute
wird logischerweise aber mit nummer eins
und zwar so jung so wenn man halt
wirklich so sein erstes date hat und
sich damit noch überhaupt nicht auskennt
dann ist es auch so ein bisschen bei uns
so man grübelt halt so was könnte man
anziehen und was besser nicht also wir
verbringen hat dann vielleicht mal 23
minuten vom kleiderschrank anstatt nur
zehn sekunden aber dann leute passiert
immer folgendes da verbringt man dann
vielleicht schon etwas länger weil okay
er nichts das outfit sitzt jetzt viele
nur noch ihre haare
hiervon diese strähne vorne gefällt mir
nicht dann schneiden weil die einfach
mal kurz habe ich gleich ganz auf meine
haare abgeschnitten
das war jetzt so dumm von mir wie du bin
ich denn jetzt habe ich hier einfach ein
bisschen verrückt hier kommen wir zur
nächsten sache die man auch noch
eingefallen ist aber eigentlich
überhaupt keinen sinn ergibt und zwar
man versucht ihr wirklich immer das
beste aus einem selber raus zu holen
und auch wenn man eigentlich so nie
trainiert man trainiert davor fünf
minuten nämlich fünf minuten drei wie
eine minute
lecker rücken ihrer siegreichen kieler
woche zu viel
heute soll sie das aus und was ja dann
andere wirklich ganz wichtig ist ist die
begrüßung die muss ja immer perfekt sein
und da überlegt man sich dann halt
vielleicht mal vorher was kann man sagen
war scheiße ich bin froh gewesen
wir fangen gleich am besten an ok alles
heil
ich bin alles sollte ich vielleicht
direkt herrlich sein man hey hey ich bin
alex und ich bin nur geil
das kann ich auch nicht machen halt ich
bin alles und ich bin alles was willst
du nicht vielleicht trennkost ist
kompliziert hmmh der wichtigste punkt
folgt natürlich am ende so das ist halt
auch eine sache die es für die meisten
jungs schon sehr wichtig und zwar will
ich das jetzt nicht verfilmen sondern
euch einfach einen text verlesen der das
alles metaphorisch rüberbringt fast
money mit einer geladenen waffe zu einer
verabredung ist eine der wichtigsten
dating regeln für männer denn der
fördern treffen den affen von der palme
schüttelt riskiert angeblich keine
peinlichen wölbung während des dates und
keinen frühstart wenn sie noch mit ihm
nach hause kommt ja das war es ganz kurz
und knackig auf den punkt gebracht will
ich mal sagen wenn euch das video
gefallen last auf jeden fall noch nach
oben da schreibt auch jetzt als mädchen
was macht ihr so vom ersten date in die
kommentare interessiert nicht wirklich
sehr slapshot ins damals eingecheckt das
api um nix ist weiter mit meinem letzten
video aber nicht vergessen dass wir hier
kommt man drauf samstag real
ist egal letztes video check das ab wir
sehen uns morgen wieder